the so-called ultimate cut of T2
includes only a few extra moments but
it's especially notable for the
inclusion of the film's alternate ending
here we see an old Sarah watching over a
now adult JN now a United States Senator
and his young daughter as they play at a
Washington DC playground revealing that
DC has gone through quite a change
between the mid1 1990s and the movies
vision of the 2020s this alternate
ending feels pretty unnecessary after
Sarah's final Highway monologue which
allows for a little ambiguity regarding
the ending of the theatrical cut the
unknown future rolls toward us I face it
for the first time with a sense of hope
T2 originally ends with a sort of
Schrodinger's Cat the future could be
set or it might not be and while it's
cool to see the alternate ending once
it's obvious why it was asked in the
first place